Howard back do you see what I deal with
every now and then on the show how are
you Howard oh my gosh trying to make
heads or tails but where do things stand
right now with Kauai best you can tell
right now sir
I don't know thanks for joining
that's fantastic right no one else no
it's like it's the one thing we're not
so ever supposed to say on radio or TV
right no no nobody it's true right I
mean it's a it's a it's if there's a
coin with three sides on it you have the
this is a coin flip isn't it right now
I'm trying to now envision the coin with
three sides and my brain hurts it does
you know is that even possible
I need a physicist to figure sounds like
something from from Dungeons and Dragons
but you know it's really like I said
what does Co I want what which which
player is he in the NBA and and I I mean
do you have a best guess as it currently
stands right here I I don't think I do
rich but I would just say this we asked
this question a lot and and I think it's
the best question for all these guys you
know every time LeBron has moved what is
it he's seeking when Durant moved what
is it he's seeking he moved again what
what it was Kyrie seeking by leaving
Cleveland for Boston and what did he not
find there that he now thinks he's going
to find in Brooklyn I mean this is the
existential question for all these guys
and sometimes I don't think even they
know I think there's not impulsiveness
to it they are thinking it through but
it's in the moment and remember these
guys are young you know I mean even even
mid-career Kyrie at 27 you're you're
drafted choice about your first team
you're forced to trade out things didn't
work out the way you expected you think
I need a new start somewhere else and so
you're kind of making it up as you go
along and you do what feels right or
seems like the move for that moment and
I feel like we need to redefine the way
we'd have talked about how players make
these decisions and I love what Scott
Van Pelt said in his in his monologue
about this with regard to Durant it's
really about happiness and happiness is
this very vague concept or what makes
these guys happy the championships is it
money is it the city is
the right teammates is that all of it
and that's going to vary depending on
the guy and with Kauai we just know less
about him than everybody else no matter
how many times we've tried to figure him
out and so I think the mystery is just
that much deeper Howard back a bleach
report here and let's get to your piece
inside Kevin Durant and Kyrie Irving's
plot to team up in Brooklyn I mean what
a fascinating inside look best guests
from what you're reporting is pinpoint
the time where they did look at each
other and say let's do this well as I
understand it what I was told and what I
reported is that the conversation began
as early as last summer they've become
friends over the last couple of years
but last summer is where the idea really
picked up steam between them that hey we
should try to play together and you know
they obviously they knew they were going
to be in free agency at the same time so
that would be possible they could make
that decision together they knew that a
bunch of teams were angling for cap room
they knew that they had certain
potential destinations in mind that
would appeal to both of them and as I
was told it Boston was even on the table
now Boston wouldn't have had cap room
and obviously things were sour in Boston
for Kyrie but as of last summer before
that happened that was among the
discussion points and so as the season
progresses and things obviously weren't
going so well in Boston for Kyrie and
Katie still was you know of the the
belief that it was time for him to move
on from the Warriors no matter how this
season ended and they were really
evaluating their options and the Knicks
and nets were both considered attract at
them because they both like the idea of
being in New York but it became more
apparent over time the Nets had a
foundation and a plan and a vision and
forward progress and the Knicks had none
of that and so at some point in the
middle of the season they concluded you
know pending any other things happening
it's gonna be Brooklyn where we're gonna
both go
alright so they'll know just dive into
that a little bit more if you don't mind
there Howard cuz you know III think you
know my stance on the Knicks and their
owner James Dolan I think you're
familiar with it I mean I am okay how
much did that play into the fact that
Durant and Kyrie moved to the Nets side
of things as opposed to the Knicks
because what I saw
Riis Instagram from the Brooklyn Bridge
and coupled that with Harvey Arden's
grace piece in The New York Times
talking about how growing up in New
Jersey he did in fact see that 2003
championship run that fell short against
the Spurs and that he he says that he's
always been hoping pining for the Nets
I mean put this all together here Howard
it's interesting and I don't want to be
overly cynical about this and then Kyrie
certainly tugged on the heartstrings for
anybody who's a nets fan or anybody who
just grows up on a team and said that's
the team I want to play for that's all
fine and I don't I don't believe that
he's being disingenuous at all about his
you know a fondness for the Nets he is
New Jersey I mean he's he is from New
Jersey right though right
and I'm not and I'm not gonna dismiss
that at all however if the Nets had
stumbled through this season if it
didn't all go well and if it were the
Knicks in fact that it had the better
year and the better young core then he'd
be walking the other way on the Brooklyn
Bridge in the same Instagram right like
it they made the decision Katie and
Kyrie I think based mostly on
basketball to their credit which was the
Nets offered them the better map to
contention the Knicks could not and you
know the stuff about the nets and the
sentimentality it's all real but I still
think he would have snubbed the Nets for
the Knicks if the situation's were
reversed with those two franchises as to
James Dolan yeah I don't know that in a
I've asked this question many times over
the years of people you know players and
agents say you know how much how can you
pay attention to the owner the front
office all these other things that that
are not immediately apparent you know do
you consider who you're entrusting your
career to and it depends on the agent
depends on the player but it's not
always discussed I don't know if Kyrie
and Katie discussed James Dolan by name
but I will say this when you ask is he
responsible for this outcome of course
he is because the ill state of the
Knicks is a direct result of Jim Dolan's
inability to run this franchise healthy
in a healthy way for 20 years
and you know he lurks from one
administration to the next one team
president to the next one coach to the
next one plan to the next and even in
the two years the Steve Mills has been
on the case they have shifted direction
multiple times so yeah Dolan is
ultimately responsible obviously even if
they didn't specifically think of him as
they made their decision
and then let's talk about the place
where Durant left
Howard back a bleach report here on the
Rich Eisen show because the
recrimination period has begun it seems
where Marc Spears of the undefeated at a
in unnamed person talk about the abuse
that Kevin Durant took there's a lot of
talk about the way that Durant's injury
was handled we had Chris Haines of Yahoo
on this show yesterday Howard talking
about how the way that the Warriors
couched his return didn't say it was
indefinite left it open and thus put
pressure on Durant to return we all saw
that he did is something that Durant had
a problem with Joe lakum comes out and
says we're gonna retire his number so
how cynical are you go about this one
started um listen every gesture by every
franchise along those lines has a little
bit of PR to it right or of you know
trying to present yourself your
franchise in the best possible light I'm
not overly cynical about this one it's
unusual look the injury stuff is very
very murky the you know every by all
accounts
Katie's own doctor or a doctor chosen by
him was involved in the decision making
process
Durant could have always said no what
happened happened I don't I don't know
that we and the public will ever know
fully where things went wrong or if this
was even avoidable I mean it may have
been that they did everything right and
it still happened that that does occur
so I just don't know and I don't think
it's knowable and I know people want to
make harsh judgments and condemn and all
that and I get it I just don't think we
know enough and maybe ever
but the fact is you know
Durant's time there had run its course
and again you know the reporting that I
that I had in yesterday's story was that
the discussion with Kyrie was that
starting my summer and yeah and long
before the Achilles we had reporting not
just me but everybody in the league
every team in the league knew this that
this was going to be his last season
there so the Achilles is not the reason
that Katie left the Warriors that agenda
had already been set months ago so how
did it affect this season I mean because
we did see the argument that bursts here
in Los Angeles right there on the bench
between draymond and and Durant that led
to a one game suspension for draymond
there has been all that speculation
during this piece I know you can't see
it but we did have the Twitter video
that went viral of Durant and Kyrie
talking in a tunnel and so how did that
affect both seasons in Boston and in
Golden State certainly in Boston where
Kyrie after if you say it started last
summer this conversation Kyrie and got
on a microphone at TD Garden and told
Celtics fans he was you know thinking of
resigning so how did that affect the
seasons Howard I don't know if that I
mean listen the Warriors were still in
the finals with a chance to win a
championship despite everything so I
don't think it affected the Warriors
season I mean it made affected them at
times it would be ludicrous to say
otherwise but did it affect the ultimate
outcome of the Warriors season no Kevin
Durant's Achilles and Klay Thompson's
ACL and the Toronto Raptors being really
really good is what affected the
Warriors up but you know we're possibly
201st having won a championship despite
Durant being determined to leave so if
that were the case we'd say if it had no
effect at all in carries case you know
the Celtics chemistry was their biggest
issue you know talent was not an issue
youth might have been an issue they had
other issues Al Horford aging and his
injuries were an issue Gordon Hayward
not being all-star gordon hayward yet
was an issue there were a lot of issues
and so you know Jackie McMullen wrote a
fantastic piece as she always does on
espn.com about what went wrong with the
Celtics this season and it's not just
about Kyrie
but did the ambiguity about his future
and him maybe already mentally being
partially out the door affected quite
possibly and especially that last series
his last few games he really did seem to
be checked out at that point
that's the poll question of Howard
before we allow him to check out of this
show Chris Howard what's best for the
NBA Kauai stays in Toronto he joins the
Lakers he joins the Clippers I'm gonna
go with Toronto because I think
stability is what's best for the NBA
overall and though Toronto is not a
small market it has not been a
destination market and so a superstar
being traded there winning a
championship and then saying this is a
great franchises a great city I should
stay here I should you know put down
stakes and also defend the title I think
is what's best for the NBA and in the
abstract I also think I'm going to the
Clippers will be phenomenal just because
the rivalry in LA would be a lot of fun
and the Clippers have have done
everything right to earn a guy like him
coming just as the net did with KD and
Kyrie I agree Howard thanks for the
thanks for the time appreciate a great
great piece and we'll chat down the line
you got that's Howard Becker bleacher
report out Howard back on Twitter for
more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for free
on BR live or download the Rich Eisen
show app